frédéric mitterrand cible de marine le
pen depuis quatre jours maintenant la
numéro 2 du front national a extrait des
passages du livre que le ministre de la
culture avait écrit en 2005 la mauvaise
vie dans lequel il évoquait son
homosexualité et son expérience de
tourisme sexuel depuis ses premières
attaques la polémique ne cesse d'enfler
et embarrasse désormais l'ensemble de la
classe politique
carline l'inter denis bassompierre mais
le ministre de la culture dans la
tourmente
objet du scandale ce livre la mauvaise
vie paru lui à 4 ans frédéric mitterrand
il évoque son penchant pour le tourisme
sexuel la profusion de jeunes garçons
très attrayants et immédiatement
disponibles me met dans un état de désir
que je n'ai plus besoin de réfréner ou
d'occulter l'argent et le sexe je suis
au coeur de mon système
je sais qu'on ne me refusera pas une
grenade dégoupillée par marine le pen
pour qui a ouvert le feu lundi soir sur
le plateau de france 2 en plus de ses
écrits la classe politique reproche à
frédéric mitterrand son récent soutien
romane polanski accusé de viols sur
mineure l'extrême droite réclame la
démission du ministre tout comme
plusieurs membres du ps ou présentant un
public de savoir si oui ou non on peut
être impliqué dans aujourd'hui la lutte
contre les réseaux de prostitution
enfantine contre le tourisme sexuel
c'est le cas de la france
et voilà et que ai constaté qu un
ministre dans ce qui est présenté comme
une autobiographie sur le site de la
fnac justifie le commerce sexuel
frédéric mitterrand dernière prise
sarkozyste de l'ouverture brandit son
indignation
c'est à dire que là mais les bras m'en
tombent et si le front national me
traîne dans la boue c'est un honneur
et si un député de gauche me traîne dans
la boue sur la joue c'est une fronde au
sein du gouvernement même si la ligne
officielle reste le soutien au ministre
de la culture
l'embarras est palpable que je sache et
frédéric mitterrand ne fait pas l'objet
de poursuites pénales le procès
judiciaire donc je peux reprocher c'est
de l'ordre du privé de leur dieu sa vie
personnelle parce qu'il faut que
s'expriment très clairement et j'aime
pas cette espèce d'instrumentalisation
politique politicienne
bayrou a fait ça avec cohn bendit
pendant la campagne européenne
je crois que les français se trompent
pas avec ce genre de comportement
embarras dans l'opposition également où
certains appellent à ne pas donner dans
la confusion des genres
- à vrai dire je suis très mal à l'aise
avec cette polémique mal à l'aise tout
comme le président de la république qui
a refusé de s'exprimer sur le sujet le
ministre de la culture a quant à lui
prévu de s'expliquer dans la soirée